knuckleduster is undoubtedly one of the
most interesting characters in me my
hero academia universe and today we're
going to be examining his former quark
now when we first encountered this
character in Chapter one of the
vigilante spin-off manga he was
presented as a reckless vigilante who
would attempt to beat up literally
anyone in his way
whether that be giant monsters or even
pro heroes but as a series progressed we
learned a lot more about his past and
his motivations for what he does so yeah
like I said we're gonna be explaining
his former quark and my solid theory on
why he lost it and there will be
spoilers for vigilantes so do watch at
your own risk
so knuckle dusters former quark is known
as overclock and much like Captain
celebrities quark it is way more complex
than it first appears so starting at a
basic level overclock allows the user to
move at super speed for a few seconds
and I'm talking like Quicksilver levels
of speed here during his early years as
a pro hero he would use this ability to
hit people with what was described as
four simultaneous punches and in this
panel we can actually see it in action
when he activates his quark to hit two
villains with four punches each all
within a couple of seconds now in parts
of Asia this gained him the nickname of
hyper quad fist however according to
Dusty himself the quotes true power is
not simply super speed but rather it is
a brain stimulation quirk that allows
the user to think see and hear a hyper
speed so essentially you can just do
normal people things just at super speed
now before we continue I need to address
one very important spoiler that will
help me explain the benefits of this
quirk in more detail as we know
knuckleduster no longer has disability
but what I didn't mention is that it is
currently possessed by a villain known
as number six now I'm fairly certain why
this happened and I'll explain later in
the video but all you need to know for
the moment is that he's shown us an even
greater potential for overclock just to
give you guys context number six does
have multiple quirks already with one of
them being a healing ability that
allowed him to recover pretty quickly
from a shotgun wound we then see that he
takes this healing ability to a greater
level by combining overclocked to speed
up his solar generation after his arm
was blown off and to help him do this he
also used these things called bomber
cells which you don't really need to
know about for this video the main point
I'm getting at is that you can use
overclock
to speed up your own biology in a
certain way and although number 6 does
have multiple quirks I would assume that
knuckleduster would also have been able
to apply in a similar way
maybe just
I don't know when he was a kid he could
go through puberty quicker or something
I don't know exactly but I feel like
because of the way we've seen number six
use it it can be used to help your
biology in some way now on a different
occasion we see number six captured by
law enforcement
but once activating this quirk he
casually gets up whilst everyone else
appears frozen and he proceeds to steal
their guns and shoot the cops whilst
they're motionless and then escape
imagine being the cops in this situation
like one minute you think you got the
guy the next you've been literally shot
with your own gun and just completely
wrecked not a good situation number six
has a super move called instant aid in
which he delivers eight simultaneous
punches on one target which is double
knuckledusters old record we see him use
this not just on a punching bag but also
to effortlessly take down this villain
who was annoying him and this villain
that he beat up it's actually a really
nice guy but for those of you who have
read for giant E's you'll know that when
he was acting as a villain he wasn't
really in control anyway the last thing
to mention about this foursome quirk is
that because it increases your
perception of things right you can pick
up on people's unconscious feelings just
by the way they move them the way they
talk if you're using this quiet you can
see the nonverbal hints that they're
giving you and you can kind of use that
to alter your response by doing this it
allows people who use overclock to be
master manipulators as they can tell
people exactly what they want to hear
and say whatever is necessary to get the
desired outcome that they want despite
all this overclock does have some
drawbacks so there's a limit on how long
you can use it for normally just a few
seconds and then once it's done you have
to wait a few more seconds until you can
use it again this is referred to as a
cool-down period and whilst it like I
said it's normally just a few seconds
it's still a period of time in which the
user of this quirk is on a level playing
field just like everyone else so they
can't speed up and yeah essentially they
can get hit because knuckleduster used
this quote for basically his entire hero
career he knows more about it than
anyone else so during his confrontation
with number 6
he explained that if a person using
overclock tries to think too fast or
accelerate too fast then it will deprive
the brain of oxygen and cause the quirk
to timeout faster than usual he refers
to this quick timing out as brain drain
and he tried to use this weakness
against number 6 by playing an audio
recording at 300 times normal speed
whilst pointing a rifle at him and the
reason he was pointing a rifle was
basically to get his brain moving faster
and activate
his flight-or-fight response also
another weakness which I mean is to be
expected if a person using this quark
suffers a concussion then that stops it
from activating as well but would that
explain let's move on to everything we
know about why it got stolen and how it
got stolen and my solid theory which
fills in the gaps
so during knuckles long hero career he
was known as the high speed hero o clock
and we know that at some point he was
attacked and had his stolen and his
face split in half this is why he has
that scar in his face ever since we meet
him in Chapter one my theory on why this
happened is pretty simple to start with
number six works for an organization
known as the villain Factory and when we
take into account everything we've read
in vigilantes to me it's pretty clear
that this organization is just a
precursor to the league of villains at
this stage in the manga we still don't
know who number six is mysterious boss
is but from everything we've seen I'm
fairly confident that it is dr. Jick oh
so I'll lay out the two bits of evidence
to support this idea and then I'll
explain why that led to knuckle duster
being singled out to lose his quark
firstly the villain factory are
responsible for manufacturing several
next-level villains this is a term for
people who have been bioengineered into
these creatures which come in a variety
of shapes and sizes now for the purposes
of this video I want to tell you guys
attention to the next level villain
known as the Bombers much like the no
moon these bombers lacked any capacity
for real independent thought and when we
take a look at the one here with six
arms it possessed a super regeneration
quark which was demonstrated when they
hit captain celebrity with an explosion
and then regrew its hands this is
important because in the main series it
is specifically stated that the black
nomas are equipped with hype
regeneration quirks and we've even seen
this with both the usj nomu and recently
with the higher New Moon when you
consider the fact that super
regeneration is classified as a rare
quirk the most likely scenario is that
dr. Yuji ko is behind creating these
bombers and distributing this rare super
regeneration quirk in much the same way
that he did for the black know mousse of
the future the second reason I'm sure
that the villain factory are actually
the league of villains is because of
number-6 himself number six is human
alias is Rikuo Nomura when we examined
this name the first four letters of his
first name means six in Japanese which
obviously correlates to his name which
is number six and the first four letters
of his last name spell out nomu so you
guys know I love a conspiracy theory all
right but they
isn't even much of a conspiracy I mean
it's staring us right in the face this
guy is obviously some kind of prototype
no moon we know for a fact that number
six was created in a lab by the villain
Factory and when he was first made he
looked like this which sort of reminds
me of those creatures made of fat from
Doctor Who ever since he was made he
spent all his time watching anything and
everything related to o clock until he
became obsessed with the hero we see in
this panel that he would watch the hero
on TV while still in his fetus form and
even up to when he was fully grown and
had the battle with knuckle duster he
still had massive admiration for him
even complimenting them during their
fight he loved the guys so much then
when knuckle duster actually lost his
quark number six carved a scar on his
face so that he could emulate his idol
this guy has like serious issues my
theory is that number six is obsession
with o clock was the intentional result
of dr. Koh's indoctrination remember
that in the main series all one would
identified good quirks that he wanted to
take well in advance and he will only
steal them when the time was right the
clearest example of this was rag dolls
quark which all-4-one said himself he
had had his eye on for a while so
clearly when it comes to stealing quarks
there is generally a bit of strategizing
here my thinking is that they
indoctrinate in number six with all this
footage of o´clock with the specific
purpose of him one day gaining his quark
it only makes sense because it's not
like this blob of flesh set up this HDTV
by himself like someone made sure that
he was watching knuckleduster for a
specific reason because this creature is
called number six I think it's safe to
assume that there were at least five
other intelligent numbers like this
assuming they weren't just failed
experiments what if dr. Fuji co-creates
these things to lead their own
operations testing out the prototype no
moves in different parts of Japan and
supplying the quark enhancing drug
trigger and in order to make sure that
they don't get captured each blob has a
quote that they specialized in from a
young age they set things up so that
number 6 would be obsessed with this
quark in the first place and so when he
received it he kind of already knew a
lot of the techniques that knuckleduster
was using at the time like to me it just
makes perfect sense that they would do
this makes him super hard to defeat and
he's used it like we've seen he uses it
in ways that even knuckleduster himself
has never seen now as we all know
knuckle duster had his quirk taken away
before the vigilante story began as we
found out that he stopped renewing his
hero license a few years ago after
stealing the quark is probable but all
for one gave it too
little gnome ooh here who already would
have had a good understanding of how the
clock works based on all the footage
that he was made to watch overall yeah
it was a very successful plan by the
league finally an additional piece of
evidence to back up everything I just
said is that the villain factory's goal
is to create a being that could rival
all mites level of power this was stated
after all might basically destroyed a
ton of these bombers like thousands of
them with just one punch the villain
factory's goal of creating a being that
could rival all mice level of power was
fulfilled five years later with the
creation of the usj nomu and when this
Nomi was introduced like they literally
spell it out for you it is as powerful
as all might so clearly the connection
is just so obvious like all for one and
huge eco are 100% behind the villain
Factory yeah that's basically everything
that was to say about his quark and
potentially why it was stolen so I guess
the last thing to discuss is
knuckledusters life before he became
Batman although we've covered most of
what we know already
sometime after his quark was stolen his
relationship with his daughter
completely broke down with this page of
the manga showing us that they used to
disagree quite often especially
regarding her fascination with pursuing
music this eventually caused her to run
away from home which then turns into a
major storyline in the vigilantes manga
and it's kind of the reason why duster
became a vigilante in the first place
following his daughter running away his
wife became seriously ill and was taken
to the hospital but she still is the
first time we see her character from
this panel it's clear that she's unable
to talk properly and she has a patch on
her eye which in the context of
vigilantes is something very very
suspicious if anyone knows exactly what
happened to his wife then do let me know
because I don't actually remember them
explaining that but because of this
eyepatch thing it just it has a lot of
connotations and yeah that was
knuckledusters former quack explained as
well as why the league probably wanted
it in the first place let me know your
thoughts as I'm pretty sure my theory
could be added to and if you haven't
seen it already then do be sure to check
out my video explaining Captain
celebrities quirk and let me know if you
want more vigilantes content thanks for
watching and peace out